-Our first guest is an Emmy an
Golden Globe-winning actress
She directed and stars
in the film "Moxie,"
which is on Netflix now.
Please welcome back to the sho
one of the all-time best,
Amy Poehler. Hello, Amy!
-Hi, buddy!
-You know, I'm going to
tell you this,
and this is a true thing,
because I believe
this is the third time we have
talked in this past year -
you keep looking
better and better on Zoom.
-Oh, my God.
Well, happy COVID-verssary
-Thank you very much.
-Every March 11th, me, you
Phoebe Bridgers,
let's get together,
let's talk about our year.
-I would like that, I think.
-I was just thinking
the other day that
yours was the first show I did
when I started
doing press for "Moxie."
and now you're the last
piece of press I'm doing.
Full circle.
-And so usually,
this would be a junket
where you would
have to be out on the road
talking about your movie.
You have been talking
about it the same amount,
but you have been at home.
Have you enjoyed
the home press tour?
-Very much.
You know,
I know it's not as fun,
and I cannot wait to be
back in your studio for sure
and to see everybody,
and to see you in person.
But, you know, one of
the misconceptions is,
I don't really like people
-Mm-hmm.
-And so it's great, because
don't have to be around anybody.
-Yeah.
-And that's great.
-Well, I think that's why people
value being friends
with you so much,
is that from the outside,
people assume you're
friends with everybody.
but we have actually reall
made it through a gauntlet
to be at a place where you'r
willing to spend time with us.
-Can literally count on on
hand. I can count on one hand.
[ Laughs ]
How many people I like.
But you make that list, Seth
You make that list.
-You know who else
is on that hand is
Maya, Kenan, and Tina,
and you and Tina
hosted the Globes again.
Fourth time.
And Maya and Kenan showed up
and what a delight they were
-What a delight.
-And it struck me,
I was confused, because,
of course, Kenan did
"SNL" on Saturday,
but then he was in
the L.A. half of the Globes.
-For people that
have not seen the show,
they played winners
of Least Original Song,
and they came up, and Tina
had written this bit for them,
and in beautiful form,
Maya arrived already dressed
and ready to party,
and Kenan had flown in right
from New York the evening before
and had not yet read the sketch,
and we were about
ready to go live.
Those two are such geniuses,
they're like stunt men.
You know, like when you se
a stunt man about to do a stun
and they're kind of
joking around
and they're really loose?
And they're just kind of like,
"Oh, you're gonna
jump off this building?"
"No, not if he pushes me first."
They're just
so good at their jobs
that they were -- it was
awesome to have them around.
They're the best.
-It should be noted,
it wasn't just reading lines
off a teleprompter.
There was also prop work.
A fantastic joke is that
Maya reached under her dress
and took off three high heels.
-She had three shoes.
-And seamlessly did it.
I mean, again,
you know me, terrible.
You put a prop in a sketch
and then you basically jus
see me staring at it
the whole scene,
'cause I'm so nervous abou
what I'm going to have to do
Whereas she, just so
gentle and perfect.
-Yeah, they're incredible.
And that night was so strange,
and you know,
you're staring at an audienc
that is separated and masked
and you can't really tell
when anybody's laughing,
because nobody laughs like -
Nobody laughs like you
think they're going to laugh
You know? Like --
Everyone just laughs like --
Like, that's maybe
how their body moves.
So you can't tell if
maybe they tipping over
or if they're laughing,
you can't tell.
So to be onstage with
that weird sci-fi quality
and with those two
was just a dream.
-I have been backstage at
Globes that you have hosted.
It is both a really
fun energy backstage
and then there's the additiona
energy of the after party.
I'm assuming neither
of those happened.
-No food or drink was allowed.
-No food or drink?
-Zero.
-So what was backstage?
-I had to sneak in carrot sticks
and my own water.
And at one point,
I checked in with Tina on Zoom
and she was eating something
I was like,
"What are you eating?"
She was like,
"I'm eating sushi."
I was like,
"Where did you get sushi?"
So that was it.
New York had sushi.
-Well, that, I think,
is the real...
You were leaning into
the stereotype of L.A.,
that all you had was
water and carrot sticks.
-Yeah, I mean,
we had tons of pills,
and we all went for a hike
-Oh, so pills were allowed
-Of course pills were.
It's the Golden Globes.
Of course pills are allowed.
-We'll be right back
with more from Amy Poehler
We're going to talk about
her great new film "Moxie.